to give you an idea of how extraordinary  the day-to-day of Tom Cruise's life is  last summer we were both in London and  we made a plan to get together and I  texted you and we said yeah yeah we're  both in London let's get together and  you wrote back can I land my helicopter  in your yard  is there anything you can't drive  how many different licenses do you have  I mean I have I have airplanes uh  commercial license Jets  a bunch of different airplanes  motorcycles parachutes boats  I have my real estate license  mechanic's license  scuba diving Scuba diving license it  would be amazing if you did have your  real estate license I would love if you  had a side Hustle